live I want to not look at this for a
little
bit want to not look at this for a
the plan for right now we're at least
going to spend a little time looking at
this and then we're going to do some
thinking about
exploration we introduce random I'm
going to just read this part to this out
loud we introduce random latent
exploration rle a simple yet effective
exploration strategy and reinforcement
learning on average rle outperforms
noise-based methods which perturb the
agent's actions and bonus based
exploration which rewards the agent for
attempting novel behaviors the core idea
of rle is to encourage the agent to
explore different parts of the
environment by pursuing randomly sampled
goals in a latent space rly is as simple
as noise-based methods as it avoid
complex bonus calculations but rain the
Deep exploration benefits of bonus based
methods our experiment showed that R
improves performance on average in both
discreet e Atari and continuous control
task Isaac gem enhancing exploration
while remaining a simple and general
plugin for existing RL algorithms
project website and code here okay
so Atari and Isaac Jim
better than some for experiments but
we're not going to have total confidence
on
that let's find the
method first of all I want to see their
definition of exploration because this
usually papers get it wrong right here
as the reward may be delayed and not
immediately presented to the agent the
agent may need to take many actions and
visit a sequence of states without
rewards before it receives any learning
signal reward as as such taking a greedy
action a at each step that maximizes
immediate reward does not necessarily
lead to a high
return okay but nobody does that thus RL
algorithms require exploring States and
actions that they may lead to low
immediate rewards but could potentially
end up with high return in the long run
we refer to this process as exploration
throughout this paper
I don't like that definition at
all I think that's a useless
definition and the reason that that is a
useless
definition um is
because that doesn't tell you anything
about the
mechanism uh by
which
well it's almost a
ndef right we refer to this process as
exploration you refer to the process of
like taking actions in general as
exploration like saying oh you need to
visit low value states to get to high
value States
like by what I don't
know I guess what it means is it doesn't
capture the human notion of exploration
either because it's like a completely
it's a definition that's completely
mismatched with the human definition of
exploration so yeah okay here the
precise my precise criticism about this
now is that this is using a highlevel
common sense human term right human like
uh human word word that we use for stuff
that we do and then applying it to
something that's completely at odds with
that so this definition of exploration
does not match what we mean when we say
exploration when we do it
so we'll see if the method is good but
right here I this definition like kind
of prevents you already from doing
anything to be fair this is done over
it's kind of you're just trying to
improve over previous action noise stuff
so
maybe the key challenge in noise based
exploration is their limited ability to
generate diverse behaviors
what's that
mean although noise based exploration
changes the agent actions at each time
step and practice these perturbations
are too local to deviate significantly
from usual trajectories okay now we're
getting somewhere as a result the
generated trajectories can appear
similar to each other limiting
exploration to a narrow region of the
environment primary technical
challenging then is diving a method that
ensures such diversity so I see what
they're trying to do the framing of it
is very murky but I see what they're
trying to do this is
reasonable randomize
rewards we have proposed enhancing
trajectory of diversity by altering the
agent rewards inspired by skill
Discovery methods that learn skills
based on different reward functions that
push the agents to visit visit different
parts of the state space for different
skills following a similar idea in every
training episode we pervert we perturb
the given task reward function by adding
a randomized state dependent reward
function
and we train policies by maximizing the
sum of randomized and task
rewards the key idea is that in every
round of interaction the agent is
incentivized to visit areas of the state
space with high randomized rewards and
if these random areas are diverse enough
we will get diverse behaviors in the
environment during training thus
incentivizing
exploration however since the random
rewards are repeatedly resampled and
thus keep on changing during training to
enable stable and effective Lear
learning both policies and value
functions must be aware of the specific
random reward function in use otherwise
the changing reward functions will
comprise a partially observable
mdp the framing of this paper makes no
sense we take inspiration from Universal
value function approximator which trans
networks based on varying goals we adopt
their approach by equating their goals
with different reward functions thus
making the policy and value conditional
on the same sampled reward
function it's making the
policy conditioned on the sampled reward
function this ensures that random
rewards no longer appear to be noise to
the
policy remaining questions are how to
implement the randomized reward function
how to make the policy value function
condition on
it randomize reward functions we design
a practical approach to implement
randomized reward function using two
principles first reward function must be
dependent on the observation must depend
observation otherwise rewards be random
noise second the
policy and value function must be
conditioned on the randomized reward
function so that the reward function is
fully observable to
them efficiently implement this and this
doesn't say anything about the structure
of the function either do product of
State feature State feature and a random
The Chosen latent vector
where this uh where Fe is a feature
extractor just means it's probably the
main
Network randomize rewards for each state
are generated by sampling
Z from a different
distribution a given distribution
pz and then setting rewards as F of s
and z
even if f ofnc is high as unreachable
Parts the state Spas agent simply does
not collect rewards and moves
on does not derail training as Z is
resampled at each start at the start of
each
trajectory yeah this is
Bizarro latent condition policy and
value networks recall that the policy
and value function must be aware of the
state and the random variable that F
that factorizes the resample reward
function f to achieve this we a the
input to the policy and the value
function with the latent factor Z
resulting policy and value networks
Pi s and z and value Supply value Pi of
s
z between late condition value Network
to approximate the expected sum of the
original reward and the randomized
rewards is
below so reward plus Lambda times this
noise
what name
is
Lambda okay so this isn't exactly J so
this is a
mass latent Vector sampling to ensure
the agent exposed to a wide range of
randomized reward functions we randomize
the lat Vector Z done by resampling at
the start of each
trajectory projector rolled out under
the same policy and latent
[Music]
Vector way to we randomize the latent
Vector Z which is done by
resampling at the start of each
trajectory
okay that's annoying as hell to
implement but sure
same
policy sampling distribution is
discussed in section
4 as we train the policy condition on
the randomly sampled Laten Z that
defines the randomized reward function
we term our method as randomized lat
exploration random lat exploration we
outline the algorithm in algorithm one
and present detailed version in
algorithm 2 in the
appendex we compute in six we compute
the randomized reward using the next
state since the next state reflects the
effect of the agent's chosen action in
state
St this choice is common in Prior
works it's also obnoxious as hell to
implement
that exploration bonus is a function of
the newly reached State rather than the
CRM
State sample fresh lighten Vector take
action receive
reward We compare R Performance against
the action noise
exploration we train using standard
experiment cuz it's not getting any
reward so this PO this is
I like how PO is above R&D and noisy
net it's funny
is a G
by yeah they use clean RL for this they
not site clean
okay so they say that this makes a big
difference
here so how much do I trust these
experiments
there's no uh exclamation Discord
command but it's just discord.gg
puffer and all the links are just on
puffer doai as well
on see the thing with all these
noise-based methods is they essentially
they rely on a random
Network producing some sort of like
meaningful smooth distribution over
different observ ations
benchmarks I mean they kind of have
decent
benchmarks it's better than the average
RL paper I give them that for sure the
benchmarks
I could see it
helping I'm not happy with it but I
could see it helping
maybe let's go to the appendix and see
how they implemented this how hard is
this to put into puffer
lib as a test
compute
feature F of St +
reward receive
reward reminds me the paper that says
adding random G noise to the
output the actor helps in
continuous uh that's a really stupid
exploration method
though that's like a really stupid
exploration
method like entropy should do that as
well for you if that's all you're doing
um
a lot of these papers that propose
stupid methods and still get results the
results are just better because they
didn't bother tuning any like any
parameters at all so essentially when
you have a weak Baseline like if you
have a really weak Baseline and you put
in some graduate student hours anything
will beat it like you could come up with
an idea that makes absolutely no sense
and tune it more than the Baseline and
it'll work
better give it a snazzy name and there
you go there's your oral
I tried it once with impulse Wars and
got weird results
yeah
well I mean this is dramatically better
at least than most of the stuff I've
seen in Exploration I'm not sure if I
like it but it is dramatically better
seems similar to this paper it's not
going to let you link the paper but if
you uh if you put the name I'll look it
up have you moved on from P30 work is
this this is for something different uh
I'm going to come back to P30 but I'm
getting behind on other stuff and uh the
p3o was giving me a massive headache so
I will come back to
Sur
group oh yeah I it's been a while I
remember this but I don't
remember what it is
skill
Z and P of Z
distribution sample environment
or step environment okay
compute
Q with
discriminator set skill
log reward equals log
Q minus log P0
yo to start should I not worry about
reducing Road points load in about
10K yeah to start just loading the
data just give something that like looks
kind of like their original s
update
policy update
discriminator just got Jason on to see
very
nice good job I've been just banging my
head against algorithms in
math is not what I usually do around
here but um we're going through
exploration papers that sounds like a
load of fun oh yeah it's great it's
second only to chewing on broken glass
I mean this does look kind of
cool yeah I forgot about this paper
here this seems better than the other
one it's funny this is like um
a much newer paper this is like a brand
new
RT oh hang
on this um this doesn't include
environment reward does it
okay so we need the version that has
environment reward right
okay the silly thing about this is that
this is these are such easy tasks like
they the tasks that they call hard or
tasks that I could just insta solve and
puff or Leb that's the thing that's hard
to know though I think and they also
only have control
P sample action from skill step
environment
compute some function with discriminator
reward does it matter if you do it on St
or St +
one I think it probably doesn't matter
that
much it's dramatically easier to
implement on
archive you have some way of sampling
onone that's not that
hard you
add a
start on
this
oops probably should do this
oh yeah do we know the uh the size of
these
things I guess it's just going to be n
right hidden size
what's the way that we do this I think I
have a function that does this in poer
Li sweep don't I
s PS two
times this is
yeah something it's probably something
like this
all right so this should sample new
skills on
then we have actions log
props state
bug so now we need to
sample we sample the scale vectors here
we have these already they're constant
for the whole
trajectories and we
need we're not going to use St plus one
we're just going to use St because it's
easier which is just o right
I'm trying to think if it's easy
to B is hidden. detach where's
hidden P30 oh you do get hidden back
right perfect I already did this for uh
e3b so I'm just going to say that this
is going to
be
um self. policy or is it data. policy
whatever
policy
dot UND
discriminator I'm going to take hidden
and
Z like
this and then
R plus
uh log of P of z uh oh they have a
sampling distribution it's not just
uniform well I can just do it like this
for now
right and then we'll
Doo check
sampling
distribution
yeah so that's pretty much it except
for except for this
bit uh and we don't have use e3b
anywhere
here so I have to do I have to add
it use uh what is
do if Ed
time and this almost already had what I
wanted in mind except it's two times
hidden size to Hidden
size re and then
hidden a hidden size
one and do I want to throw a tan on
this I might want to throw or sigmoid on
it welcome back thank you we're working
on something a little different now to
give me a break from hard things
we went through this paper from Pit's
group I had some misgivings on this I
got suggested this paper which I don't
know how I forgot about this because I
think that this was a big thing when I
was at open AI was this 2018 or
2019 yeah 2018 then I'm pretty sure that
we saw this while I was at open Ai and
it was kind of cool um but I completely
forgot about it until I was just
reminded
so we're going to try
this and it seems like it should be like
relatively fast relatively low overhead
as
well and then all we need to do
is update discriminator with
yeah this is a large paper lots of
experiments very tired grad students
um where is this thing
though we need the loss for uh the
discriminator to be able to finish the
implementation
discriminator we maximize what on Earth
is
objective s and a are random variables
for States and
actions Z is sampled from P of Z as a
latent
variable we condition our
policy we refer to the policy condition
on a fix Z as a scill
I and H refer to Mutual information and
Shannon
entropy they have code for this they've
got some [ __ ] notation
here oh do they not have code for
this I just need to know what the uh
I just need to know what the objective
is
discriminator
loss cross entropy loss with logits and
Zs wait logits
is do
split self-d
discriminator and then you just do cross
entropy
loss of the discriminator Logics with Zs
which
out oh you just literally wait is this
thing trying to produce its own skills
I'm
loss props minus Q
okay for. split
pz wait
huh oh yeah this is just the forward P
bit of it right
they've done some weird stuff but then
the actual loss
is
discriminator and then
Zs which is just the original sampled
skills
right where
so we just have to store the skill
Vector used at each
step I'm going to paste this in
oops I just want to know if this
implementation is likely to be correct
all right that's not going to tell me
much let's hope that this is correct for
now and uh let's just implement this as
is because otherwise I'm going to start
getting
bored um
we need to include then an additional
thing in the experience buffer right let
me not cover the chat so
okay di whatever
B and then when we do store
there that's
all now we have this stored of course we
have to add this to the eval
Loop and we're almost ready to test this
thing or at least to make sure it runs
and it's not actually going to use this
Cuda
kernel it'll cash it so it won't take
long the next
e i
a a
[Music]
we don't really care if we make a little
bit of a mess in the process of doing
this because you know these changes
don't get kept unless they actually work
broadly lstm wrapper has no object
whatever discriminator okay
add d i
a what do we call it here
easy uh it's just going to be a DOT
right
yeah we can kind of just
do hidden
this so
that
uhoh and you have to pass both of these
don't you hidden Z no
indices oh wait we we don't
need hang
on experience
dot I don't know why I can't spell
archive
attribute Okay cool so this actually
does give us
try
this they should now give us a sampling
of new
skills if I can actually
spell now every so often I wonder about
coding all doing all my coding without
an LSP and then I go nah it's probably
fine well it
runs here's the restro from I'll be back
in a minute you can see if that does
okay well that's a pleasant surprise for
once um an algorithm doesn't completely
crash
learning assuming it's actually getting
used let me say
m we need to add this to the Bater now
don't
we will you take on games like Dota or
Starcraft 2 nope and not because of the
RL component but because they run too
slow for me to do so at a a reasonable
scale you need like minimum thousands or
tens of thousands of CPU cores just to
run the games fast enough to keep up
we will take
on
relatively complex problems though that
run
faster so the whole idea here right why
I'm doing this um I'm pretty darn good
at making progress very quickly on
things when I can keep things lean and
keep things moving fast I don't want to
get like bogged down by like a really
Capital
intensive uh you know heavy weight Ms
this sort of stuff that's like where
things just RL progress grinds to a halt
so the way I'm doing stuff now in puffer
it's pretty easy for me to just be
making progress very very quickly um so
anything like that where we're working
with something heavier we'll do that in
the context of like you know assisting
with a company that's trying to do
something like that for their own
purposes but for our core stuff we're
focused on keeping things really lean
and really fast
that said we now do have multi-gpu so
you know if there's Hardware you can run
stuff
faster we have people using puffer now
on Multi node too
right I can actually do this at the
bottom
do
Z Varan
this one does
need to be indicus or B
flat be flat
uh
oh I need to replay the discriminator
don't
I that's
annoying yeah I
do that's really annoying
policy forward train and I don't get
hidden do I I'll don't get the hidden
State back from
oh lovely it's already in the right
uh it's already in the right shape
somehow and I do have an
oh yeah cuz it's already uh reshaped
correctly for me that's
nice I think it's hidden in
Z it's data.
policy
it's just cross entropy of Q and Z isn't
it
almost done we almost have this whole
thing implemented so this wasn't that
here Criterion
is cross entropy loss
um n
skills wait out
features equals n
R hidden
q but then it goes to end
skills oh so it's trying to figure out
what skill this goes to I guess
but then how's the reward defined I
think I have the math a little wrong
this
pz s. pz.
okay and where do they get the
discriminator the first
time they get it
here easy
equals easy.
gather so they take log soft
Max of The
loget
Gather Zs
plus
log
pz + 1
so does any anybody understand how the
hell this
don't you get
log
zns okay log soft Max I understand log
soft match of log logits is fine but
then you index it
with so you're just taking the index of
whichever one this corresponds to
I can do
yeah you need the
indices so we'll do
that oh I had the wrong G type in here
anyway so this is
better for
skills
archive the archive IS F
self. D YN skills
equals Rand
int batch
size is this batch size I don't think
this is batch
size I think I need this to be
numm which is the same as the lstm state
so it's lstm total agents
this all right I thought this would be
easy there's a slight hold up
though still not that
bad do you think it'll matter at all if
I drop coordinate values of the
positions from float 64 to 32 no not at
all right this is roughly what it needs
to be we need to just fix whatever I
made uh whatever errors I've made
he was looking at setup not try to
building box 2D without
cmake they don't distribute pre-build
archives
lovely I guess you'll have to make the
pr with uh with cake
then build
archives you could do that as
well that would also work
do you see how the argument though for
cake is literally like it's because
everything else is hooked into seake
it's the cancer argument right it's like
because there's some cancer over there
you need cancer
here moving to cmake will be a large
task sounds good let's like not do it
for now
what oh what happened
here oh wrong
size easier to work with and maintain
see I'm not sure it
is is the
Fork yeah you can PR whatever the box
that's
fine that's totally fine
has reward on
CPU may want to explain that to me
drive me crazy with
this gather minus one and then the index
right
maybe it's
this oh I think take is One D
indexing yeah that's
wrong e
a that should that's weird this should
work
triggering how the hell is this
triggering that
probability tensor contains okay imper
NS
cool lovely
see
so log soft
Max maybe
it's I think I did this one
wrong yeah yeah I did hold on this is
log soft
Max s Max
q. gather
now we can now get the discriminator
lost as well
do
that and
is it immediately optimized to zero or
something
see so they
say hit the
discriminator do log
enough where is it torch
dot gather
pz it's pz.
gather
and then they don't update this anywhere
right
one over n
skills so that's literally all it is
okay so this pz is just dumb and then
you take log soft Max of the
logits along Index
so you get
logits and then
on discriminator stop
backward wait what hang on why is it
negative
okay so this does not
train and this loss is immediately zero
weird discriminator
opt discriminator lost stop
backward cross
entropy so you're predicting what Z it
came from
okay so that's weird right
because this is you're perfectly
predicting which one it came
that oh no that makes sense
actually cuz it's per trajectory fine
me does that look optimized to you it
doesn't look optimized to me at
oh no it is learning
this okay so this thing is correctly
predicting where it came from then
perfectly really though in One update
it's doing that for
is why is everything got to be so fre
complicated man why why all these papers
have to be this way
this should be simple it's just like
very confusingly
written okay you take log soft
Max right and
then the
reward Max entropy loss
this thing output outputs logics
torch. split next
States and states and
skills I don't understand this split
oh wait maybe I'm not supposed to give
it maybe I'm not supposed to give it the
skill Vector I'm
confused compute
Q
Z given St
all but wait how do you do condition
on Z here
but how do you condition on Z
then action has to be conditioned on
Z does this get added to the op
space maybe it
does I see okay that's why I have it
wrong
do we use this
we
don't why do it got to be so
fancy cuz now I have to pass this in
don't
and then the discriminator doesn't
condition on Z
right no it just conditions
on the state so we do one
hidden new algo
freaking driving me nuts all these
arguments I don't think you
need don't need Z at all here do
you no you don't you just need
hidden and then you have to pass though
to
train how this get past
this yeah you need the
uh where's this
this now it shouldn't be able to whoops
now it shouldn't be able to
predict hello fighting yes fighting
algorithms Okay cool so now this is the
sanity the sanity works here if you
don't give it the conditioning it can't
predict
anything if you do give it the
conditioning uh it can
predict
now how do they initialize these
I don't know where these get these get
initialized
the the
archives okay the Z is the reason that
they uh they don't have any is because
they're making them dynamically and
they're making a stupid one hot so
that's silly it's literally a one hot
the way they have
yeah the discriminator is just getting
instantly optimized that's
and what was the network that they had
on
this yeah they have a three layer net on
this I only have a two and I still learn
it
oh wait is it no hang on hidden
one no they've got two layers it's fine
it's the
same States
reu oh no they do have three because
this is the
output
interesting interesting
GPU is fighting for its life as well
with whatever the heck this thing is
something I imagine you're not supposed
to have zero loss like basically
immediately
here my but I checked it and it looked
like it
was predicting
correctly is 128 like way too many
skills
let me think about how this is possibly
just
like instantly
predicting so you pass where is
said we're passing in
where's the
discriminator there it is so we're
passing in the hidden
State the hidden state gets
Z
okay and then from the hidden State
we're trying to reprod Z I guess
right that looks like what this
is for
one gather Z yes that's
right and
then that's the
reward and then it's just cross entropy
to train this thing right
wait is this supposed to be log softmax
here that looks
weird maybe it is maybe it isn't hang
on
discriminator so you take log soft Max
for the
reward you do not take log soft Max
here so I don't know why I have
that oh I don't use it I don't use it
anyways
do this loss
coefficient the
loss I mean this looks totally right to
me
then let's just be sure that this is
actually doing what we think so if we
don't add the
reward I don't know how it's this slow
either
slow why there's something weird with
that like it shouldn't be that
holy hell what is taking this long like
that doesn't even make any
yeah this is not supposed to be anywhere
near this slow
stupid okay so you can see right
there this massive freaking
difference use a restroom real quick and
then we'll figure out what's wrong with
this
okay something is like completely
crushing CF
here
right what would it be
okay
so
overhead not in
is this cross entropy really that
slow oh hold on I
know do I know let me
it's just telling me that this subnet is
very
slow is like frost entropy is not a
particularly slow lost to compute for a
small number of classes is it I didn't
think it
if you let it run does it still
train so taking the uh the reward bonus
off
I think I must have broke something
else there's no way that learn should
take this
long and it still doesn't work
okay for
thought that would be
it maybe
something is just like really screwed up
here
now this is still
slow this cannot still possibly be slow
there's nothing freaking running that's
different there's literally nothing
running that's different for
it's in
the it's in the learning Loop too is the
weird thing
policy unless it's like doing something
weird with it
I mean this is insane right like how the
hell is it
let just make the [ __ ] train step 10
times slower for no reason day
apparently I'm not even doing anything
that should change
I'm like baffled as to what the hell
this could
this is cursed this is [ __ ] cursed
like what the hell it's just uh I
don't I don't know what is do what's
happening here this should be the same
as the original the only thing I can
tell is this extra Network
exists and learning is just way slower
for no apparent reason
literally not even using it in training
at
I'm going to figure out what this is if
it's something stupid I'm going to be
really mad
[ __ ] okay it doesn't even have the
freaking loss in here anymore like
doesn't even have the network to have
the loss right
me torch is so [ __ ] stupid that it
will just broadcast that tensor and make
like some insane gigantic value loss
that's insane okay yeah I'm mad [ __ ] you
pie
ridiculous just broadcast to a gigantic
value loss like oh yeah that's
stupid now we know why it wasn't
freaking doing anything
at least it's not something wrong with
the method but I'm mad about that one
maybe they don't do dot product maybe
they can
I don't see how this is going to break
learning
completely that seems very weird
see I don't understand how on Earth this
could break
anything this is the
problem I don't understand how this can
break
I don't understand how that like
concatenating some random thing can
possibly screw up learning to this
this immediately immediately learned
right you put this garbage on and
nothing works
stupid codee's just a
mess fine whatever
there I'm just getting irritated I've
been doing this [ __ ] all day
somewhere it should still work with
random noise
dare okay it takes a little longer to
ignore the random noise
does it
work you got to be kidding
me you can catenate a little random
noise and it's just broken
you add a bit of noise and it totally
screws you
up are you healed up
um I mean not remotely compared to how
fit I was before I was
sick um I it's going to literally take I
mean if I were like actively just like
trying like if it were like my main
focus to get back into that shape it
would be six months of hard training
it's probably going to take me a year
with all the work I've been doing lately
I mean it's Saturday I got up at 8 I've
been working since uh since 8 and I'll
probably be working more in the evening
depending
and I'm usually fine with that though
today I'm just mad because today I've
been working all day and haven't gotten
jack [ __ ] done because these algorithms
are fiddly and they kind of just
making good progress today I wish but
not
I mean the thing that's really going on
here is just like we're doing this
research a little bit early um there are
like core fundamentals that I should be
addressing before this in RL where
things are just like utterly stupid and
nobody's bothered to fix them for 20
years and it's like it's almost to the
point where it's a miracle that anything
in RL has gotten done at all because the
state of the field is so bad that you
like you basically have to burn phds
like PhD students 20s in order to get
the smallest bit of work done um and
that is fixable that is a fixable
problem but it requires a very very
different approach than what I'm
currently doing
here but at the same time it's like yeah
I kind of have to try out existing
methods and stuff on puffer because
people want these for their problems
that they're throwing stuff on right
I mean literally we're at the point
where I have magic
hyperparameters where like
um if you train it works perfectly but
if you can cat a little like concat a
little bit of noise to the
observations uh even if it's like very
small amount of noise it just breaks
training not add it to the observations
concat it to the observations still
breaks crazy for
how the hell do they add this thing this
is
insane do you have a team we have open
source contributors working on uh
various environments and such but as for
like the algorithm work it's mainly me
okay that's something at least
here why do they have this term like
isn't this term just fundamentally
but that's not going to help now it's
just a giant negative
can
you this plugin's going to drive me nuts
stop
it thing I wish I could just disable
multi-line completely on this thing cuz
like I never want a stupid AI writing
multiple lines of
code it just writes garbage every single
time
finally five times as long because of
the
AI in my damn
this oh yeah so uh Brad if you're still
here I should mention that um
the core stuff is me but uh we do have
more people working on puffer adjacent
things for
companies um as
contractors but that's purely for uh
that's purely for like business side
stuff I mean not business side stuff in
the sense of like admin but um on
technical stuff for
clients the core Dev on
puffer is uh is
right what kind of things are businesses
using RL for
uh got ndas on that at the moment but I
can say it's like it's various stuff
it's like some of it's industry RL
research some of it is in like uh
robotics control type stuff and then
there's uh new stuff that's Finance
adjacent it's just like we don't really
have a specific RL area as much as we do
general purpose RL tech for people who
need like simple RL thrown onto their
problem very very fast and um you know
with some of the stuff that we use as
well we've got things like good hyper
pram sweeps which are very nice for
solving new problems without taking
forever um you know we have like a very
fast trainer implementation we have
stuff so it's relatively easy to add
stuff into
it as frustrating as this is right here
today um this would be like a
frustrating month in a different RL
Library instead of a frustrating day I
wish RL was focused on more than the
current llm Paradigm yeah I mean so do I
but it's fine there's still plenty of
applications there's still companies
doing it it's enough for us to be able
to uh keep this
are you self funding all of
this well yeah it's a company though so
it's bootstrapped we have
Revenue we don't have as much revenue as
I'd be making in industry but we do have
Revenue
I mean I've been doing this less than uh
less than a year and except for like um
except for like big Hardware purchases
like it's well on its way to being
I didn't even like consider going for VC
because it's just going to add it's just
going to add strings attached that I
don't want to deal with
do you see RL surpassing every other
form of learning no I think it's going
to be used in conjunction with other
forms of
learning hey Will how's it
going we've been fighting [ __ ]
algorithms all
day but at least we have uh this is now
going to
be uh the old like Serge's diversity is
all you need
algorithm long time yeah what have you
been doing have you just been in llm
land working on l or like what have you
been up
to sick to see the progress yeah we've
got got training up to a Max of uh 2.5
million steps per second depending on
the config uh and we have really really
good hyperparameter sweep stuff and
we're making some progress on the new
algorithm it's very difficult a lot of
math but we're making
progress I think that this works
cool so this will run hopefully not
break we will see whether this actually
learns anything
reasonable it's not a great environment
for it to be fair but we'll
see working on
computer using agents now more like vpt
large
scale computer using agents now more
like
vpt oh yeah I know a guy who was wanting
to do that but yeah that makes sense
cool I'm sure you have fun compute
budget stuff to deal
reflection no they're doing code agents
I think right that's the other Deep Mind
guys
stealth is General
agents that sounds like generally
intelligent that means you have about
one year before you've uh you're going
to
Rebrand oh yeah we have uh 22,000
experiments in here so far mostly just
for me running stuff on one one node as
well
that's fun as [ __ ] as
cool the RL stuff is fun except when I'm
dealing with like the previous RL lit
like everything in puffer is fun and
then as soon as I have to go outside of
puffer to like some existing thing in RL
it's just God
awful but I guess that shows you kind of
what progress we've made with puffer
right
need to get back to puffer yeah I mean
it's
like the neural MMO three stuff is going
to be whoops I honestly think that this
is going to be such a good environment
as soon as we have uh you know some
stuff running a little bit more stable
I mean this is like the small version
that we did for web right and you can
just see all the agents running around
Dynamic economy items levels like all
sorts of stuff skills to skills to
train so we have environments we have
fast training we have hyperparameter
sweeps we just need a few last things
before we can really start scaling stuff
tricky speaking of which the uh the
current
project this was just like a quick side
thing for a client but um the current
project I'm attempting to replace
generalized Advantage
estimation who did the art for neural
MMO they credited
I probably should even though it's just
a purchased license but um it is
credited in the
repo with what it's a learnable version
of J that doesn't require stupid lamb or
gamma
parameter it's
this you buy a license per um per
project they're pretty nice required a
lot of
pre-processing well the thing will is
here I've been fiddling with uh
different versions of
this it's a variational value function
that predicts a whole bunch of steps
ahead paper link there's no paper link
you're oneshotting the multi-agent team
they couldn't get out of their own way
dude iMac I'm really really trying and
to be be fair one of my favorite things
that I I'm a little bit annoyed that I
didn't end up there fulltime but the one
thing that I will say that I find very
funny is uh the project that they did
right after they left that I left was
the
um uh what was
it hide-and seek yeah the hideand-seek
stuff um the main thing that they were
interested in were the transfer results
on that I told them it wasn't going to
work I told them exactly the reason it
wasn't going to work and and W and
behold if you look at the appendix all
those experiments just went into the
appendix as eh they kind of don't work
so unfortunately it took me
um it took me an extra like five years
to get the engineering experience to do
everything like really really well now
but I think we're in a good spot to do
this
now I the thing is that like in order to
really make all this stuff work and work
well I just needed to have the
engineering experience to know how to
build stuff a THX faster than they were
doing it which I now do so now we can
actually have everything run like we're
training 2.5 million steps per second at
the most and 1 million at least on
average so if you look at like clean RL
and sp3 usually training speed is
between 1 and 10,000 steps per second so
we're between 100 and a thousand times
faster so that means I can now actually
run all the experiments I want to and
have a really really quick feedback loop
for Dev and uh you know I can full train
breakout in about a minute and a half so
you know I actually don't have to be
like I don't have to be running stuff on
something as trivial as like a five-step
grid problem I can just do stuff on like
breakout or pong or whatever and it runs
in like a minute and then I can run
stuff on you know our harder M and have
that take like an hour right
that's been like the really big thing
but now it's going to be a matter of
using that to improve the
algorithms this thing is driving me
nuts yo I think I have the Sim rendering
work want to take a look on
Discord
absolutely let just
hey what's up hey
Spencer all right let me uh let me just
share a screen real quick yep it has
been a crazy crazy day of like algorithm
hell but oh yeah I'd like to help you on
this end it's just been ridiculous I got
one thing implemented at least I think I
got pretty
good if I can uh just share my screen
and not have my MacBook break in half
mhm all
right do you
holy yeah so there's no there's no real
like uh so this is stepping through all
the time steps as you can see um but all
of those are just pre-loaded into memory
so there's like step isn't really doing
anything besides incrementing it's just
incrementing time step by one dude this
is so obviously it's at like 6 million
plus steps per second but I mean even if
you just added an action and they have
just random action you'd still be there
so I mean that's just kind of where dude
this is this is sweet I mean I don't
know for sure if like the lines are
actually all correct or like where I
mean they look good but I mean I think
that's correct I mean I just haven't
actually checked what the you know
original one is supposed to be I was I
was gonna send a video over to the the
the team on slack and let them and ask
them if they had any if it was screwed
up at all I mean I think at this point
you just like so this is like the naive
one where it has to if you have the
compute observations you have to Loop
over everything right I have no
observations in here yet yeah but if you
were to do it like have to Loop over
everything right correct correct I just
Loop over everything just do that get
the agent step thing to work and see how
fast training is just like out of the
box CU it would be hilarious if the
completely optimized versions already
faster yeah I mean this is this also has
this also has no um or CPU Drive what's
it called like no no segment uh what it
called polyline decimation algorithm it
it it just has all like 10,000 uh dots
on here and in segments they don't we
don't care we'll optimize like the point
is I want to just get the naive thing
first yeah yeah and then we can go from
there and like specifically the fact if
you keep it naive and you keep the code
like the code small enough it's going to
be easier for me to help you actually
come up with the data structures that
we're going to want yeah I mean this is
all using the entity struct so this is
all um I put it all into the enti array
and the most annoying part was really
just like getting the Json file to
actually go to the right yep um stuff
but the whole thing I think is like a
few yeah I've I've used multiple scenes
so I can load in a different scene okay
so uh yeah I think just like get the get
the train Loop working at this point
with like the simplest possible thing
and then just be like hey this is so
early but already I like the thing is
they train so slow that even with zero
optimizations like if you use the
multiprocessing back end you're probably
just gonna win I'm pretty confident I'm
going to get to a million on this one I
mean with you're gonna get with naive
observation looping uh maybe but
see we'll see okay like just you know
i000 but it's still going to be faster
than I mean I don't have any Collision
checks going on right so you know if we
wanted to go like do we want to do
collisions or you just want to get like
early training of just saying like hey
initially don't bother and then we'll do
it after okay yeah I just want to get
like here get actions going like have a
train in some capacity yes and you know
I'll try and match the OB the
observations somewhat um their
observations are a little bit different
because they did like the segment type
thing and this is all smaller ones so
well I'll figure something out but I at
least think I'll be able to get
something hopefully training by tomorrow
is my goal do you mind if I uh if I puer
theme the colors yeah yeah you can
[ __ ] pu theme the colors dude I don't
give a
[ __ ] the thing is it actually kind of
matters because it keeps uh it's uh you
know it's puffer branding
yeah yeah fair enough um but yeah I mean
I think the maps turned scrolling around
you like oh look yeah yeah I have 3D
camera movement going on this this was
like a little annoying but you
know the lines of code yeah uh nothing
dude uh 300 something for the h file and
200 for thep file well done well
done so and I mean I'm certain there's
things that we can change whatever but I
mean if hey if it gets to a million then
I mean I don't know who cares let me
just message you one thing cuz we are in
stream but I'm just going to message you
one thing real quick on the
side kind of sick though right it looks
all smooth into
it all right that was all M uh I I was
going to send a screen I'll send a video
recording to the team
and give them you want me to send that
give an update after we do training or
you just go ahead and do an update
now uh what do you mean give an update
like just go ahead and share a video
recording of this to see like if it's at
least visually correct with the scene
that they have sure for whatever if you
want to you can just be like hey here's
a quick initial thing still working on
it yeah and then and then whenever we do
training I'll do another update after us
training speed going
yeah Okie do all right I just you
something as well that you may or may
not be interested in uh let me
uh yeah yeah that sounds that sounds
pretty tight I'm here for that yeah I
mean you've done a great job on all
these ends
so let just yeah
uh let me say you something but um yeah
we'll just handle this up not stream
yeah okay that's fine we'll off stream
send you yeah I'll send you details but
it's going to vary I don't have like
upfront info on that but yeah we will
chat yeah yeah I'll just messages we'll
chat on some Discord stuff um no worries
but yeah that that's where we're at and
uh we'll see we'll see how it gets
training and uh you know maybe we can
even just like Crush some results and
then uh then did the project
I mean this is what kind of expect is
like they have all this code but like I
bet you can just do it faster in a tenth
of the code with no engine so yeah no I
mean this this is literally nothing in
terms of lines of code I did this this
afternoon um or really pretty much all
day today um okay I don't I don't know
if I could have I don't even know if I
could do it that quickly you've gotten
pretty good at these
ends um if I if we can do something
that' be super sick to you know rename
it drift if is cuz you know like how
Japan CH like modeled their entire city
in terms of like Point clouds okay like
what if we just like Drop Like an entire
city and then put like
10 uh oh you're cutting out but yes drop
entire city into Puffer that would be
hilarious yeah like just drop entire
city make it GTA Tokyo yeah
and because all those Road data already
like done by Japan to some degree I
don't know if Lane data is in there but
I mean at least Road data I mean you can
kind of
extrapolate where Elane would be just
with requirements okay Tokyo puff Tokyo
puff dude Tokyo puff that's funny okay
cool
anyways I will youve been doing some
cool stuff we will sync on this soon uh
let's do that after you get the just
initial train Loop doing something I
think it should be like it should be
pretty easy with what you know now to
just get like the agents to go to the
goals if there no Collision checks right
yeah yeah yeah I think it should be fine
I'll see like what OBS even I'm curious
to know what OBS are even necessary
because I feel like the OBS
are vention than goal necessarily but
you know oh if you wanted to you could
literally just put like agent position
goal yeah yeah yeah that's that's what I
was thinking I mean like yeah just do
that for now just like super simple and
then we we'll deal with the other
complicated stuff later on um I mean it
but yeah I think that'll be good to
start uh what's your philosophy for
ocean M contributions a few super high
quality M or spread the net wide uh the
individual M don't have to be like crazy
complex as long as they are useful as a
training Benchmark in one way but the
code does have to be good um we do like
to try to keep the code quality high but
the thing is it's it's really not that
hard if you just look at the way we've
written some of the existing ones it's
literally like first year undergrad
level C it's Loops conditionals and like
that's it so
yeah okay well thanks for the uh thanks
for the quick update and the Prototype
SP I am going to it's 5:30 I'm G to
spend the next hour trying to figure out
if I can get the new algorithm to do
something it's it's a real mess like the
math is the Math's a
pain all right I'll peace out later see
you
bye that was cool
um yeah that's awesome I didn't expect
him to have it done that quickly it's a
nice
prototype you know sometimes you don't
know if it's going to be 300 lines or
600 lines without like doing it yourself
so uh yeah I wasn't sure but that's
cool okay um we'll let this run and then
we will go back to the3
math so since there are some folks who
were not here for this this morning
this is an attempt at replacing
generalized Advantage estimation which
or
context this is kind of misleading that
this only has 4,300 citations
because the PO paper's 24,000 citations
and really the core piece of it is this
so this is like I'd say arguably the
most important piece algorithmic piece
in RL and we're going to try to replace
it that is the
goal and I think it's actually kind of
doable I'm just getting stuck on a
little bit of the
math so this piece that is difficult
here in spe uh specifically what we are
trying to
do is we are trying to replace these
discount factors of gamma and Lambda
with just a learnable uh per time step
gamma Factor so instead of having this
you have gamma zero Gamma One gamma 2
gamma 3 without the
exponent and the idea is that that
should allow you to learn uh the
importance of
samples over time without having to just
tune a discount Factor per
environment there are many reasons to
think that this would be better as well
but at least we would like to match je
performance without those additional
parameters um now the thing that I've
gotten stuck on here is this gamma has
this nice property where it decays down
to
zero but uh the value function that we
are using with our gamas don't have that
property our gamas Decay
to they Decay to the standard deviation
of the reward I believe
or to the standard deviation of the
return let's look at the math I have so
far so I'm replacing gamma
this okay 1 over Sigma squ Sigma is the
uh predicted
standard deviation of the reward minus
one over the true stand uh true standard
Dev deviation of the reward
squared so this is our confidence in the
sample less the uh the base confidence
like if you were to predict randomly the
base confidence so this is supposed to
be how much more confident are you in
your prediction than random or than
see and I don't think I see any reason
that this doesn't just
work so maybe I just was getting
frustrated this morning maybe I'm
actually way closer
working because there was another thing
that I was trying to do earlier this
morning that I don't think made sense
and I kind of just burnt myself out on
that maybe this is quite
simple maybe it is
here is let's just get the for up by one
side and we'll see where we went
wrong Advantage
scale vstd rstd
right what do we pass
here rstd
okay so it's going to be 1 over vstt ^ 2
minus 1/ rstt 2
and then these get summed
this
return is equal
ah I
think I think I
okay yeah so what's happening
here this is setting this
buffer to the discount Factor at each
time
step and
then this is equal
to the sum of discount Factor over time
step I'll use
mean
I I don't think this is correct
yeah so this index is wrong first of
all and then also this
buffer is not uh is also not being
computed
correctly okay so I'm seeing the errors
that I made this morning and I think I
was just tired so let's see uh if we can
do better now
bounce I think you need
advantages duns rewards
okay reward block math values mean
vald
turns
DS
step
okay let's SK this signature oops
then this also needs to be matched so
this is reward block
mask value standard deviation returns
data
pointer
rewards
either reward block reward mask values
mean d
deviation
turns
oops DS
Horizon
bstd and then this
one block MK means
deviation
turns rewards
duns
Horizon it know it's numb
steps B
TD
then you
return returns
this now becomes
returns and this stays the same
needed
[Music]
this does not need to be a
vus
this do advantages.
zero guns
rewards oh it's
returns yeah this is returns my
bad doesn't need to be of
indices turns.
Zero DS or is it was it rewards
point we'll fix whatever we got to
fix and then we will adjust the kernel
J equals uh was it
K minus
one Z
rewards I don't even know if we're going
to need this reward block reward mask
Shenanigans we'll
oh no you know what we might still need
it we might still need that for the uh
the value
law okay
so the next
we do R plus
equals gamma
times
[Music]
w
returns of index
r five and now you do not need any of
this
annoyingly if you uh if you killed
during compilot breaks
ah it actually gets past this now
perfect
back
returns self returns. reshape this fine
and then
advantages it's also
okay returns are always zero for some
dumb reason
J is K minus
one greater than zero
here then
no nothing weird in
here ah
do these not get
returns this K minus
2 and get minus
over this is quite a big right this is a
problem
yeah this is what it
was okay so why does this happen
okay so I have the scaling completely
off
one I thought I wouldn't need that
anymore
but I guess I hadn't thought of this
scaling
maybe
not I could Norm it so that gamma come
to one and just see what
zero rewards is all
zero returns is going to be zero because
rewards zero
either well there's more work to do on
this but uh this is at least there's
some progress
made I'm going to see whether I do this
after dinner or
not let me see uh about the ablations in
the meantime
see if this does
it all right I may or may not be back
after dinner if not back
tomorrow um yeah thanks for watching
folks a lot of algorithm Dev today check
out puff. for all my stuff start of the
GitHub to help me out and uh you can
join the Discord get involved and follow
on X for more and